so anyway you you came here because your
knee was killing you you had swelling I
looked at your foot so this thing right
here
you were a little embarrassed yes to
come in here because you maybe thought
that I was you were too bad I wasn't
going to work on you
yes I thought if I come with the walker
inside the office doctor gonna say you
have too much problem sugar high blood
pressure cholesterol ease go out from
this office then I I was hiding but I
was crying and I say doctor I'm I'm in
pain I'm dying he said don't worry we
gonna fix it today and he did so so do
you really need this anymore
no no so I'm gonna eat a two-top so this
thing when you seem to get this out of
here because you came from your sister
from Germany right yes and both of you
were diabetics right now the doctor is
actually lowering your medication I
think your sister doesn't even she's not
even taking medication anymore and her
blood Sugar's are 106 106 and then you
for the first time last night what was
your blood Sugar's when you woke up 104
this number was I was looking more than
a few years I never have that number
because always when I woke up it was to
10 to 5 but right now exactly my blood
sugar is 1 and I feel better you know
that is the point I feel much lighter I
don't have any more headache Wow now
what about your sleep last night
Oh doctor I don't want to wake up this
morning I was complaining I wanna stay
home all right
oh my gosh yeah and then you're you're
you're walking so and you're swelling is
better what you can then actually next
day my sister told me and I'm sure
you're all pain is gone I said not all
pain but more than half a pain I don't
have that much pain and I feel much
better I took shower and you know doctor
I just I wanna tell I love you I love
you too thank you
the other thing too is that you've tried
a lot of things
to lose weight yeah in the past ten
years I've been I went to Weight
Watchers yeah
and was good but it was for temporal
then I took the doctor at Kane and
program just protein doesn't work for me
doesn't work because everybody losing
weight except me and I didn't know why I
have too much water in my body and I
didn't know what's that doctor explained
to me and I'm learning I said today I
think I finished the University I let a
lot of thinking about this course
see one thing I really I really like is
is I I really love that your your
understanding the why not just what to
do but the understanding of the body
because our whole message is to get you
to understand how your body works and to
make you be able to control your own
body rather being dependent on pills and
medications so that's really the goal is
to educate reeducate you on the truth
about it and then to get you healthy
that way you'll never end up on this I
think your sister is showing you a
question or something about em because
inside the mirror she showed me today
how much water came from my body and
she's right after I'm wearing this pants
and this pants is too big for me she
told me believe me
you lost a lot of water from your body
and I'm sorry more myself I know
everybody I know everything except my
body and right now I learn about my body
I read book I asked the question this is
really changed my life and I'm so so
glad I'm here I'm thankful to God and
I'm thankful to the good doctor thank
you so much you don't know how much my
sister was praying for your acid you
don't know it's doctor it's unbelievable
good we go to doctors doctor said you
high blood pressure and the doctor my
blood sugar was before you are not gonna
believe me eleven eleven point eight
and I asked my doctor since a1c they
won't see and he said I'm sorry I cannot
do anything because go do something
every day they said add the medication
and I came home and I was crying and I
said my husband I'm gonna die because
this blood sugar is too hard right now
you say well thank you and I'm so glad I
mean I'm so good I mean thanks God
thanks God for this opportunity for me
and for my sister that's fantastic
you're leaking all your electrolytes out
now you're gonna be dehydrated ok thanks
so that was a great case study we'll see
in the next video